was basically involving uh it was very
ambitious but it was all
to do with the fact that the white king
is stuck in the back rank and maybe
there's the possibility of advancing
your pawns and keeping the king caged in
okay so black's trying to go active
black's trying to use both of his rooks
on this second rank
i and now the bar is getting excited
finally the bar's getting excited maybe
black just had to grit his teeth and
take white's porn
white's corn upon that and just hope for
the best and pray that he was
able to save that game and stop white's
remaining important is the only chance
it was the only chance but this way
it feels like he's just okay but this is
a little bit sneaky right
so i mean the whole concept is that
after pawn takes pawn
well that could be a mistake because of
the rook coming down
and the two rooks would align themselves
on the second row
and the white king would be in danger
okay so magnus actually with 10 sec
just over 10 seconds now it's going down
critical moment
is there more than one winning move i'm
not so sure anymore he does take that
pawn off maybe it was better to actually
ignore that pawn
um that pawn wasn't actually going
anywhere so suddenly magnus's advantage
is slightly disappearing and that is
because black's rook
now can get behind if you look at the
pawn on the b line the very far advanced
white pawn
blacks work finally can get behind it
and maybe try and pick it off look at
the clock
okay oh he made that with one second to
spare wow
gosh keeping us on the edge of our seats
so uh
okay now if i were magnus i would just
simply hold on to that pawn
he goes he's active instead okay still a
nice idea
yep a nice idea there one second
did he make a move yes he did two
seconds to spare
but now magnus is about to gobble up a
second pawn and
two pawn advantage yes he's lost what
his fire advanced past pawn but
he's gonna get an extra pawn on both
sides of the board this should be
winning for magnus
okay now he swaps off a set of rooks and
that is game over
we mentioned as soon as one set of rooks
come off the board black has no more
counter play
no more attack against the white king
and all magnus needs to do trade that
set of rooks
protect your pawn in the corner there
and slowly but surely you'll create two
past pawns
and those will overwhelm black's army
right exactly and the pawn that's there
on the left is kind of more or less
the decoy that's going to hold just tie
the black rook down
and uh there's just really nothing to be
done here
and magnus pushing his pawn forward
there's nothing you know what to do rook
takes rook king takes
and now black if anything black can do
is just wait yeah and the
there is a saying that all rook end
games are drawn it's kind of
tongue-in-cheek
uh but not all record games are a draw
not when you're two pawns up
uh when they're two healthy pawns as
they are here and there we go magnus
just taking kind of baby steps just
stepping one square forward with his
pawn next he'll centralize the white
king
and yeah dupoff i'm i'm impressed he's
playing on
that shows uh shows optimism but
yeah magnus he's again the end game king
he's not going to let this one slip
and okay yeah it looks like dubo is
about to give up
yeah he knows that it's inevitable he
can slow things down but
the result is not going to change
white's slowly going to step forward
with his pawn there we go
black's rook will be tied down stopping
that pawn and then white will make a
passport on the other side
and that will be the that will be the
final straw that breaks the camel's back
you do both thinking is there anything
he can do
to trick magnus i guess that's not it
nope unfortunately not he's trying to
trade a set of pawns he's hoping for
some stalemates he's gonna
try and trap his own black king and hope
that uh
hope that magnus walks into some uh
tricky stalemate there that was
that was very uh very cunning but magnus
he actually brought his rook up
releasing squares for the black king
right exactly and uh it's like that
whole hall of a
whole note song like i can't go for that
no can do
so uh yeah very nice and uh we have
results magnus carlsen wins against dan
odubov
yep he gives up daniel dubov a great
game by magnus carlsen
and a great win for him